oby what are you doing right we are all
done filming Waldo however we can't
export any of the shots because we don't
have the software yet we can buy the
software thousand dollars so it's pretty
expensive guys over at color have
graciously offered to give us a free
license for the software which is great
but we're still waiting on those keys so
in a previous vlog video you may have
been able to pause and see our upload
schedule that we've got taped on the
wall over there oh my god you're gonna
you're gonna pause on that one to are in
originally Waldo was slated come out on
February 15th and it is not anymore the
video is not done we don't have the
software for yet and so we haven't
enabled to do any of the editing let
alone sound design and music we don't
have enough time to finish the wallet
video even if you were to buy the
software like today it's gonna come out
at the end of February the 29th I
believe but that's ok because we have an
ace up our sleeves let's just see what
happens there it goes let me show you a
trick let's your my computer on I don't
want to be on anymore I got turning off
real fast so all I have to do is set my
computer on my lap and the computer
turns off I'll fix it wait that that
well that's the one that they sent me
back do you want to email them no I
think it's just a loose battery plug
sensor has a proper like screw driver
thing that takes you screws out
we fixed the laptop looked inside
nothing was like obviously wrong the
cushioning pad on the inside was missing
it's basically like this kinda like foam
ish type material that insulates the
motherboard from the all aluminum case
so I cut out a little section sealed it
all back together and have her anything
back so I'm missing me it's working
Kronos has been having issues we got a
new motherboard put it in trying to get
the OS on there keep in fingers crossed
just plating game at the month four
years ago we bought a TV really
expensive one real basic real big fax
never actually a television they've
always been given to me and they've
always been like in decent enough
quality couldn't justify buying a new
one people just give them to me so how
heavy is this thing moderately good job
I'm adding the hard drive and it's been
at 4% after about an hour he's been
trying to format that entire time
yeah not good well is it possible that
the motherboard was fine this entire
time it was just a bad SSD how about we
take it and throw it off a bridge with
that fix it
you